our next guest made history with her
performance at the winter olympics team
usa's aaron jackson won gold in the 500
meter speed skating event in beijing
this week she is the first black woman
ever to win olympic gold in speed
skating and the first american to win
the race since 1994.
the 29 year old picked up the sport just
five years ago people and she joins us
now in the studio erin good morning and
congratulations hey thank you thank you
we are so proud of you first of all i
can imagine
what does it feel like to be sitting in
this moment with that gold medal around
your neck but more importantly you've
crashed through a glass ceiling for so
many people now they see you
yeah i mean it feels amazing i mean
there's just like a lot of happiness a
lot of relief a lot of excitement and
yeah it's just it's a lot a lot of good
things speaking of people seeing you um
we have a message from a couple of
people okay that want to say
congratulations can we roll that clip
for aaron
jackson gayle here oprah here we just
wanted to say give yourself a round
aaron i'm so proud of you listen i never
even learned how to actually get the ice
skates on like putting skates i couldn't
even
go in an ice skating rink so what you do
is like
it's so
above and beyond
expectations yep what a winner what a
winner we're so proud of you this is the
thing eric i used to know how to roller
skate i'll bet i can't do that now and i
know there was that little kerfluffle
with the metal you put it on backwards
all i know is that it was still gold on
both sides so congratulations to you my
favorite picture you skating around the
rink with the american flag ah that was
so beautiful so beautiful cheering you
on always can't wait to meet you
bye
that's cool gayle king oprah um it's two
of the best yeah but you have the whole
world um supporting you how does it feel
it feels amazing i feel like that's like
kind of the best part it's just getting
to see like all the reactions all the
messages it's been really cool
so you know just i mean you think about
where you are in history i mean uh
vanetta flowers was the first black
athlete to ever win gold in the winter
olympics and that only happened 20 years
ago
and here you are breaking that glass
ceiling as michelle talked about oh yeah
i mean i just hope that it's not 20
years before uh before the next one you
know yeah yeah let me also ask you about
something we were talking about earlier
this morning about the pressure that
athletes all athletes but specifically
uh valeeva the young singer the young
skater from russia she's 15 years old
what do you think of the fact that her
coaches are sort of tough on her in
front of the world everybody looking
i i've always believed that all of you
all athletes no matter what country you
come from or compete for are all in it
together right what did you make of what
we saw um i didn't actually see that um
sorry i've been just like so focused on
my racing and like kind of like staying
in in my right mindset um i haven't seen
a whole lot of the other controversies
going on but but you applaud your your
fellow competitors for sure for sure
yeah i mean it's i think it's really
important that we all support each other
and i'm just really lucky to have um you
know a really awesome crew behind me
with like my coaches and my teammates
it's just been amazing yeah speaking oh
sorry i know we want to ask that same
question go for it oh and and speaking
of you know coaches and the crew of
course they help you but um people see
that gold medal and they think oh she
must be been skating her whole life yes
that's not the case right you started
skating in 2016. so clarify this was it
speed skating in 2016 or did you put ice
skating for the first time in this video
because this is 2016.
oh my god it's his first time on the ice
on the ice right whatever
all right i've been a skater a roller
skater my whole life wait wait time like
oprah just said it's like roller skating
you can't be ice cream so we started
this clip and in 2016 you step on the
ice gingerly
ten minutes later you're moving around
on like
you've been doing it for years that
right there is black girl magic you
can't tell me anything different i mean
i feel like you know like uh my crew at
toyota like they just say it best like
it's never too late to start your
impossible and i feel like uh i don't
know it's it might seem kind of
impossible but you know just got to put
the work in for sure for all the late
bloomers out there i know you know
uh the ballet dancer misty copeland she
started at 13 ballet you had hakeem
elijahuan started playing basketball at
15. what that says is it's pretty too
late never too late okay i have got to
ask about brittany beau of course oh my
gosh one she won a bronze we're so
excited for her but i i still the
allyship of this young she's actually
older than you she's been in more
olympics but the allyship friendship
teamsmanship of this woman
i i can't say enough about it right and
i mean i don't feel like i can ever stop
talking about it you know it's just uh
it's so amazing and it's just hard to
imagine someone making like that sort of
a sacrifice for you and i was just
yeah it's it's amazing she's an
amazingly selfless person for sure it
was such a selfless act yeah now you're
from ocala florida right you're just
talking during the commercial break i'm
not sure in ocala florida they have a
ton of ice skating rinks and they're
pushing kids towards this sport so for
someone who might uh
might be raised in a similar situation
what do you say to them about taking an
alternative route to success because
oftentimes places like ocala
it's basketball or football you can
either dribble your way out or go score
a touchdown right but what do you say to
kids that might be looking at you saying
i want to be like her
for sure in line speed skating
yeah i've been an inline speed skater
since i was 10 years old and it's just
like an amazing pathway into the olympic
sport of long track speed skating
so my coach renee hildebrand
she's still in ocala coaching brittany
beau is from the same city another
medalist at these games joey mantilla
he's from ocala we're all from little
ocala florida all started out on inline
skates so i'd say that's definitely the
uh a good pathway in i want to know what
to know yeah cauliflower shout out got
it well congratulations again thank you
so much for joining us
the great aaron jackson